la nouvelle situation née de la fin de
barkan la salle le mali devant le fait
accompli et laisse mosaïste à une espèce
d'abandon en plein vol nous conduit à
explorer les voies et moyens pour mieux
assurer la sécurité de manière autonome
avec d'autres partenaires
[Musique]
la ministre des armées a souligné l'
indécence et le caractère proprement
scandaleux des propos du premier
ministre malien qui un jour après le
décès du caporal-chef blasco laisserait
sous-entendre que nous avons ou non de
malice qui n'est absolument pas vrai
d'une part un dialogue extrêmement
étroits nourrit régulier existe entre
les autorités françaises et les
autorités maliennes
[Musique]
mon livre est signé les six personnes
venues de stationner biasini h n'est pas
idiote et parce que le coup venir je
n'ai pas dire que ce chrétien est ce
système on étire taux à 10 ans se tend
pas ma gatti est ce que les
nationalismes anja brésil est ce que tu
cherches ne réussissent que bayonne et
compagnie
minimes 4 monica co votre machine
[Musique]
la situation de sécurité n'est pas bonne
au mali en effet les dispositifs par cal
le dispositif du g5 sahel le dispositif
de la minus marc le dispositif européen
ne sont pas performants et par
conséquent il a en effet dit à des
journalistes en marge cette intervention
à l'onu que le gouvernement de bamako
recherchait un peu partout des
possibilités de résoudre ce problème de
sécurité
[Musique]